let's bring in the Bengals head coach
Zack Taylor joins us on the program
coach good morning where are you right
now I'm upstairs in my house is that
where you're going to be draft night it
is yeah I got I got a decent setup here
where I can deadbolt the door and keep
my four kids at bay
have you home good luck with that how
have you guys done a rehearsal draft yet
yeah we not not quite a full reversal
yet but we feel comfortable tour headed
you know we kind of get new memos every
day from the league and what it's going
to look like I think as this week goes
we'll have a great feel for what it's
all going to look like and iron out all
the kinks what's your biggest concern
you know for us I really don't have one
stand to be honest with you we get to
pick the first pick of three of the
first four rounds where it's a new new
day so to speak you know to where we get
18 hours to figure it all out and decide
who we're going to pick so I don't think
we'll quite face the challenges that
everybody else is going to face just for
that reason of all the years for this to
happen it's kind of set up well for us
obviously in the later rounds we'll be
on the clock and you got to sort it all
out but we got a very flexible crew who
can adapt to really any challenges that
come forth and we've been we've been
using a lot of different forms of
communication here over the last three
weeks and haven't had any problems so
far as the Bengals organization decided
on who you're taking number one overall
I think we're really comfortable with
the direction we're headed I'm not quite
ready to make any major announcements
yet but I think we've done our homework
here the last three or four months and
kind of vetted all these guys out he'll
really come forward the direction we're
headed is their scenario where you would
change who you're taking it doesn't look
that way you know I think we've if
there's a guy there that you believe in
that can really change the franchise
over the next 10 15 years then that's a
hard thing to pass up on and you know
people all the time ask me what would it
take to give up that pick and if there's
if there's somebody there that people
are willing to give up a lot for that
they believe in you know then that just
that really verifies what we think about
those players as well so exciti see how
it all shakes out next week how much of
a separation do you think there is in
abilities between Jill Burrell and the
rest of the quarterback
quarterback candidates well I think
they've all you study them all they've
all done things to put themselves in
that conversation from number one so
sometimes I beauty can be in the idea
beholder a little bit some people may
think of one guy differently than
another you know they've all won a lot
of football games and put themselves in
contention to play for championships and
and the biggest thing of all those guys
they made those around them better and I
think that's a that's a key attribute
for any quarterback is does he raise the
level play of everybody around them and
you see those guys they got the most out
of some of them had great talent around
them and they got the most out of them
and so so credit to all those guys for
putting themselves in this conversation
how does being a former quarterback help
in this process makes it fun you know
because you can see you can see some of
the situation's these guys have been in
that maybe you've been in before and
I've always enjoyed watching
quarterbacks more so than a lot of the
different positions just because in fact
I played that position so it's fun
talking to them I'm asking how their
brain works a little bit you know
talking to other players about them and
it's just it's been a really fun process
over the last three or four months
learning about what makes all these guys
- what's the number one characteristic
number one trait that hat you have to
have in your quarterback ladies a winner
you know you want guys that are used to
winning know how to win know what it
takes and most importantly knows what
the standard looks like and oftentimes
guys come in to have a lot of talent
there's no question about that but they
might not know what it looks like and
and what it takes to be great and so you
want that guy that's going to come in
and raise the standard of everybody
around them and say that losing is
unacceptable we're not going to endure
another year like we had last year and
make sure that everyone gets to most
other abilities and that's that's the
number one trait you got to have what's
Andy Dalton's future with the team well
still in a contract and so you know I
always like to say that all options on
the table because they truly are but but
amy has meant a lot to me personally
Minamata this franchise over the time
he's been here and you just gone about
his business the right way and so again
we're just trying to make the best
decision for the club right now and
we've got some more time to make that
it's a nice insurance plan if you have
him there it just feels like that that's
the new gameplan Zach where you have a
quarterback but you have to have a
legitimate backup quarterback as well I
think it's worked both ways you know
I've seen some teams have a lot of
success with with veterans back there
and some that maybe have younger guys
and so you know it's it's all about what
the organizational approach is and we
feel like we got great quarterback
coaches in the building as well a lot of
guys who spent some time around some
really good ones but but again it's if
amy still around and then that's a great
setup to have for us talking to Zach
Taylor the Bengals head coach former
Nebraska quarterback can you believe
Nebraska didn't recruit chill bro he
told me that he didn't he didn't get
recruited he was heartbroken so so you
know I think it's fortunate for
everybody heated up at LSU they're very
happy he's very happy wait how did you
end up in Lincoln you grew up in Norman
Oklahoma didn't you I did my dad play
yeah I'm
I was sooner born I'm soon regret and my
dad played there and was a captain there
I was very good coming out of high
school band I went I went to Wake Forest
for two years then I went to junior
college and then Bill Callahan came and
recruited me he was kind of going from
an option offense to West Coast offense
and I happened to be the guy there in
the junior college ranks that he thought
could help him and just very fortunate
how it worked out I'm watching the
YouTube clips you look pretty good don't
do that don't you don't need to do that
no I you there at standard-definition
you're the big 12 Player of the Year I
think offensive player the dear players
have they seen this stuff they don't
need to I've gone through some you know
some YouTube conversations trying to get
that removed from the internet but so
far I haven't had any luck with that
how many guys on the roster could you
beat in a 40-yard dash zero that's a
that's a fact zero I think most of our
linemen I mean they don't look at the
combine times but I did not break 540 so
there's not many guys I'm going to be
especially now 15 years later there's
very little chance I want to be able to
do that how nervous are you going into
this trend excited no nerves you know
we've we got a great scouting Department
you know Duke Tobin this gives them done
a great job getting the coaches aligned
with where we need a head and you put in
all the work for three months it's like
getting ready for the season
you know it's you're prepared for it you
can't wait to see how it all shakes out
begin we continue to have great
conversations you know even this week
still we've got some more to be had to
sort it all out but it's gonna be
exciting and not only for us but I think
for a lot of people that get a chance to
look forward to watching something on TV
and some sort of competitive event I
guess you could say but I'm excited for
it have you been told by the NFL to not
reveal who you guys are taking no no
okay that's just a decision we've made
you know to again just use all the time
we got and there's no reason to do
otherwise but but again we feel very
comfortable the direction we're headed
right now no I you know to get Joe
borough is it makes it makes all the
sense in the world you you got to get
that quarterback you got to get that
rookie deal so you got four or five
years to play with with the salary cap
you know I get that and you know
Cincinnati's developed very good
quarterbacks you know through the year
so I I know people keep saying ladies in
Ohio guy he's not a Cincinnati guy you
know a long ways away from Cincinnati
there but you know when I met him he was
very impressive Zach he that's a guy who
is confident and overly confident I
thought very but I think in a good way
it feels like guys follow him he's got a
great edge to him you know I think
that's the best way to put it yeah you
know you can talk about confidence and
all that stuff quarterbacks but he's one
of those guys that put in the work and
so he's got the confidence in his
abilities because there's not a lot of
unknown out there for him you guys put
in the work and they're ready for the
moments the moments not too big for him
and you know we've got to know him we've
got to know a lot of the guys there in
this conversation over the last couple
weeks we've we've really maxed out that
time talking to them and so it's again
we feel comfort all those guys that stop
do you
his Jersey already made up I don't have
any jerseys made up on anybody okay I'm
just okay I'm just carry any changes to
the uniforms this year I you know I
think there's always little adaptations
but you know sometimes those things come
across my desk after the draft you know
it's not about something I spent too
much time worried about right now
well you're an advisor is that what you
are I can be an advisor for you I know
fashion I can be a lot of things I can
be a lot of things fashion is not
something I usually like to stick my
nose into you know some people feel
certainly very strongly about certain
things when it comes to jerseys and
helmets and that's not something I've
always really involved myself in looks
like Brady we're gonna be seeing him in
a Tampa Bay Jersey like that's gonna be
really there's certain things where you
go you know I'd never thought like I'd
see Larry Bird in a different uniform or
Magic Johnson and like you know just
certain things and then all of a sudden
Brady's gonna trot out in that Tampa
uniform ain't weren't you a Buccaneer
for a couple of weeks for a couple weeks
that's the right way to put it you know
I had my rookie minicamp debut probably
I must not have gone very well because a
couple weeks later got that phone call
and just told to unpack my bat was
literally it's literally packing my bags
to go to training camp I was hitting up
that last day I just taken engagement
pictures with my wife it's a great day I
wasn't in the last bag there that's
driving to the airport I got the phone
call saying hey we're gonna release yeah
so I had to trot back down the stairs
and let everybody know what happened so
that was a tough one but you know I
think I think I got the most out of my
abilities I wasn't in a football player
can be very happy with the career I had
but but your wife wasn't marrying you
because you were going to be a star
football player in the NFL like that it
didn't I don't think we'll ever know you
know we've gotten far enough down the
road just it was too late to turn back
very engaged and an L for kids how old
are these kids
my boys are 9 and 7 and my girls are 3
and 1 and and I'm very grateful right
now that they're not in school because
my 9 year old he's all caught up in the
stuff and so he comes up here and we'll
watch tape as I'm watching some college
guys and I know that I cannot trust him
at this one if he does
my guys were taken there's there's no
trust factor there with a nine year old
so unfortunately we got a 14 in the
house and he doesn't quite have the
ability to communicate with his friends
so I feel very very safe with that
information I getting out that's who I
should have had on the nine-year-old
he'd tell me what's going well have fun
Zach and it could be one of those
moments where we look back 10 years from
now and say you know Bengals turned
things around bye-bye this draft so good
luck with it yep dan thanks a lot Zach
Taylor Bengals head coach